قول كل قطاع غزه ولكن نتحدث عن اشتباكات
مسافه صفر وفق اعلانات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه نتحدث عن المناطق الشماليه من
قطاع غزه لا تزال المناطق الجنوبيه
الغربيه من مدينه غزه محور مهم للاشتباكات
رغم الانسحابات التي تمت من المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه
ولمدينة تها بدرجه اساسيه منطقه الرمال
الجنوبي تل الهواء اطراف الشيخ عجلين
الاطراف الشماليه لحي الزيتون والاطراف
الغربيه لحي الصبره اذا ما دخلنا بصوره
اقرب لهذه المنطقه كتاب القسام وسرايه
القدس تتحدث عن استهدافات مركزه ودقيقه
لامرين اساسيين اولا لتجمعات الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في هذه المناطق اذ
تتجمع الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في
اطراف تل الهواء والشيخ عجلين بهذا الشكل
في هذه المناطق اذ انها تتخذ من من
المناطق الجنوبيه لتل الهواء مرتكزا لها
منذ بدايه التوغل البري قبل عده شهور
وتمركزت عند شارع 10 خلال الاسبوع او
الاسبوعين الماضيين وتتقدم نحو الشمال
لكنها خلال الفتره القليله الماضيه خلال
يوم الثلاثا الماضيه كانت تستهدف منطقه تل
الهواء ووصولا الى منطقه النصر بهذا الشكل
الذي نشاهده على الخريطه تقدمت قوات
الاحتلال اسرائيلي عبر شارع النصر وفي هذا
الشارع تدور اعنف الاشتباكات بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ا
كما ذكرنا نتحدث عن نوعين من الاشتباكات
اشتباكات بالمسافه صفر تضرب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بقذائف الياسين 105 وايضا
اشتباكات بعيده المادى نسبيا التي تق تدك
فيها المقاومه الفلسطينيه تجمعات الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه كما ذكرنا في هذه
المنطقه منطقه التحشد العسكريه في جنوب تل
الهواء وفي اطراف تل الهواء ولكنها في
المقابل تقوم المقاومه الفلسطينيه كما
اعلنت خلال الايام القليله الماضيه وخلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه بالمناسبه بضرب
التجمعات الاسرائ في هاتين المنطقتين
منطقه الجامعات ومنطقه الجوازات واستهدافه
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه من المسافه
الصفر كما اعلنت سرايا القدس وكتائب
القسام هذا المشهد مهم للغايه في المنطقه
الجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه غزه لان
الاشتباكات عادت من المسافه صفر كما ذكرنا
مع توغل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عبر شارع
النصر وقنص وقتل اي انسان يتحرك على هذا
الشارع المشهد ذاته يتكرر في المنطقه
الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه وتحديدا اذا ما ذهبنا
الى منطقه خانون المناطق الغربيه لخان
يونس والمناطق الشرقيه لخان يونس لانه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يسعى للتوغل في هذا
المربع الذي نشاهده على الشاشه المربع
الذي يضم مستشفى ناصر هذا المربع الصغير
هذه الدائره الصغيره التي نشاهدها على
الشاشه هي التي حتى الان لم يستطع
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التوغل فيها رغم
الضغط الكبير الذي شكله بهذا الشكل نحو
هذه المنطقه والضغط بهذا الشكل نحو هذه
المنطقه اذا ما دخلنا بصوره اقرب لهذه
المنطقه نشاهد مستشفى او مستشفى ناصر او
مجمع ناصر الطبي ومستشفى الامل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تتمركز على بعد حوالي
300 متر فقط بهذا الشكل على شارع البحر
هذا هو شارع البحر الذي نشاهده على الشاشه
باللون الاصفر وهو الذي الان شارع الموت
اصبح لان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقنص
اي انسان يتحرك على شارع البحر اذا ما
دخلنا بصوره اقرب لمستشفى ناصر هذا المربع
او هذه الدائره في هذه الدائره حوالي من
خمس الى ثمان مدارس للنور ومدارس الحكوميه
تحولت الى مراكز ايواء اي حركه على شارع
البحر يتم قنص المتحرك فورا لان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تتمركز عند هذه
النقطه عند محيط مسجد بلال بن رباح على
بعد حوالي 300 الى 350 عن عن مجمع نصر
الطبي في الجهه الشرقيه وهذه المنطقه بشكل
عام تخوط فيها المقاومه الفلسطينيه
اشتباكات من المسافه الصفر مع اليات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
بشكل اساسي من المنطقه الشرقيه على بعد
حوالي 300 الى 400 متر من المنطقه الشرقيه
لمجمع ناصر الطب